hey folks we might be drunk as brought
to you by sheath the official underwear
of Comedy I bet I'm wearing them right
now
yeah what's a better uh promo than that
I'm not but I usually am no he's wearing
panties US Army soldier Robert Patton
knew there to be a better way to keep
your dicks I'm sticking to your leg and
sheath was born every pair of sheath is
a soft flexible cradle-like pouch that
separates the boys from the inner thigh
eliminating sticky situations I love
them they look great they feel great you
got to get the balls in the dick a
little space it's like Israel and
Palestine down there sheath comes in a
lot of patterns and they're ready for
any occasion they didn't leave out the
ladies either we got boy shorts sports
bras and bikini briefs go to
sheathunderwear.com use promo code drunk
to get 20 off your first order every
order comes with sheets 100 money back
guarantee that's sheathunderwear.com
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
and let them support your balls
[Music]
hey guys how are you hey I wasn't ready
sorry a little jumpy been a long weekend
keep going Nice Kicks oh the honest baby
wow look at that it matches your Pepto
bottle in the Green Room this is the
Pepto this is the Jewish pair of
giannises uh we've got a special guest
today uh Dustin Nickerson new special on
YouTube it runs in the family March 28th
March 28th there you go YouTube's the
move baby yeah I saw Chad Daniels last
night he's doing one uh I already just
did one you know he's so good yeah
they're out there yeah that's for people
playing the how many times Mark burps
and farts drinking game at home early
early yeah
I mean more you've gotten more burps and
I've gotten words so far sorry we're
going we were talking baseball before
you got here because you're like first
off you're wearing a Seattle crack in
here yeah yeah you're a Seattle guy I'm
a Seattle guy and but I don't know
hockey so I'm like a fan because it's a
new team but I'm like what's icing like
I don't know the rules yeah to the game
yet and I almost don't want them to
because like they're pretty good right
now they're like first in the Pacific
and but I almost don't want them to win
because I haven't suffered along with I
haven't hurt yeah I haven't read it yeah
yeah it's like a comic yeah getting too
much too right right you didn't pay your
dues exactly like as a kraken fan I was
like no I gotta especially Seattle which
is a very long-suffering sports city
originally that city is just it's it's
like suicide it is number one it's are
they number one I think they're number
one and suicide right no of uh Alaska
wow
Syracuse too but I'm like that's another
one you can't even count it like a real
city right and if you think about the
things that like Seattle's known for
like coffee and music art software
indoors also the coffee's also like
energy it's weird to be caffeinated and
then kill yourself oh good point yeah
really need it they're high energy
suicides right you know that they don't
lull it's a it's a high energy they
couldn't get off the couch to jump
without a charger so actually coming in
at number one with a bullet is Wyoming
oh that's another one nobody lives there
and it probably takes like a week yeah
that's a state too we're going City here
oh City but you think Seattle you think
like Frazier you think like you know oh
Niles yeah yeah you'll start like a guy
hanging himself no the weather we were
there recently and by the way more
theater is like the most beautiful fish
that's one of the best places in the
country I think that might be my
favorite venue we played so far yeah I
opened for Nate there a couple years ago
and it's like I grew up going to this
and like Allison Chains has a famous
live album there oh yeah you're just and
like Houdini played this wow I know
you've got crazy Pearl Jam climbed the
thing there yeah I feel guilty doing
what I do when I hear [__] like like
Houdini played there and I'm like here's
a here's another abortion joke
keeping that tradition on well you're
he's making things disappear too
but also Seattle Kraken that's the the
animal the weird what is that Kraken
it's like a monster right it's a sea
monster yeah it's a very Seattle weird
name but it's kind of a cool name it is
a cool name and they have the most
Seattle name ever for the uh the arena
the climate pledge Arena
I thought you're gonna say the syringe I
think they should call it the sound
garden
yeah it was
very cool
yeah
I think Jerry Bruckheimer is one of the
owners oh wow
you Google it
the reason the Kraken exists though are
to try and get the sonics back like the
oh is that right Sonic's lost yeah we
lost the Sonics in 2000s and and it was
like a thief in the night type situation
where uh Stern the CEO at the time gave
his bunny Clay Bennett a team in
Oklahoma City and they were like ah the
Arena's trash it was a Key Arena it was
fine you know but they had to like
renovate it and show that it could be a
good space to now try and Court the NBA
back to scene wow what a move yeah they
should they should have a team it's
pretty I mean I grew up on those like
Sonics
green and yellow yeah yeah
shrimp cool team good years yeah just
another all another set of Hall of
Famers that Jordan kept from getting a
title
which is your legacy of the 90s yeah
that was I mean speaking basketball I
did I did Giannis on the kindercumpo's
benefit last night yeah holy [__]
amazing family they're so cool shout out
to Hassan I'm sorry awesome Hassan Minaj
uh he put it together and it's like
literally mayor Adams the Ambassador wow
up to Greece and then me holy [__]
oh thank God okay I got a buffer but uh
it's crazy I'm doing literally I'm just
like I went up like half in the bag I
was like I'm [__] nervous I'm looking
at mayor Adams wow so I had an easy gig
I was a few Manhattans Deep by the way
Stavros whatever he was supposed to come
with me he didn't long story but I'm
like I I'm like I know I'm gonna get
drunk so I just start pounding all this
like really great Greek food they had so
nice uh I'm looking in the front and I'm
I'm trying not to make eye contacts the
front table is Giannis the nasus and
their mom everyone's like people were
like crying before they bring me on
they're just like this incredible woman
yeah who brought these men up to to be
such and they're like all incredible
people they're all good human beings
yeah they give back and Giannis is the
greatest basketball player right now I
think you know if you if we're going
yeah two-way great freak yeah and and
and I look over and the brothers are
laughing and I was like thank God and I
look to the left the mom is not laughing
I'm like it's okay the brothers are
laughing that's what's important yeah
yeah and then look over mayor Adams
[__] loving me oh really right and
then pull up the video Matt after the
show right here
because stav did not come with me
wow Greek gods wow you're a good friend
move yeah I do a dirty friend mode this
I didn't ask for the video we were just
talking and I said I'm so bummed because
my one of my best friends was supposed
to come with me tonight and he and he
couldn't come and he's so upset about it
and he goes let's make a video for him
oh
wasn't there he literally texted me
before he's like I can't wait dude I
can't wait can I wear my Greek uh can I
wear my Adidas tracksuit and I was like
I mean it's the Rainbow Room dude it's
like yeah I was the worst dressed person
there and I was in the button down you
know and uh I was like you should
probably wear something you know I'm
like and then he was like I'm look dude
I'm looking around I don't have one
dress shirt and I was like you did five
shows at the Wilbur this weekend you
don't have one dress shirt and he's like
no I don't have a dress shirt so I was
like [__] it just wear the track suit no
I don't want to drag you down like I
don't want to like be that bad plus and
I was like just do it it's fine and then
he fell asleep
I was explaining to a friend and I was
like I was like he just fell asleep I
was like hey he's fat as hell yeah
it's happened yeah that people just fall
asleep yeah it happens you hear cat naps
you never hear a fat nap you're gonna
say you just showed up in a toga
Luke because that is the uh the Garb of
the day now he uh he was PR and then I
tried to swam when I was there because I
was like dude the entire Milwaukee Bucks
team is here wow and he loves the whole
team so he's kind of like dude comment
he just he woke up to that video like
[__] damn my wife would have showed up I
did like 10. yeah that's not anything I
got I got a big laugh and I was like
[__] it I didn't even get the light yet
I was like [__] him off yeah
I was like there's no need for me to
overstay my welcome and a benefit right
wow and you sat next to him no I didn't
sit next to you I just I found him after
the show wow
he is he is well dressed too really he's
a Dapper oh man he's an easy guy to root
for like I don't think anyone hates
Giannis no Papa's yes but
very different honestly very different
yeah different energies yeah
wow that's right that's a that's a what
do you call it a milestone that's fun as
hell yeah great awesome the man for
doing that yeah that's awesome we gotta
get him on one day do you have any uh
yeah we do have to get him out do you
have any uh do you have any wrecks any
wrecks like recommendations oh
recommendations yeah uh sure yeah I'm
always like way behind on like TV and
like it's like that old Gaffigan joke
you know you remember the show game I
love this joke it was like I'm I'm gonna
mess up the exact details right it's
like you ever watch a movie oh that's a
great joke yeah hey you guys ever seen
heat
they're like yeah like five years ago
but I want to talk about it now yeah I
love that I want to talk about heat now
I want to talk about heat now that's the
perfect movie that's a little bit of
like the parenting thing like because we
like I get like me and my wife like if
we're watching a show it's like 40
minutes at the end of the night and
we're like we can start a new thing or
we can watch Larry Sanders again like
something we know it's amazing how many
references Larry Sanders has gotten on
this podcast oh really
yeah he literally answers the phone hey
now oh that's right yeah that's what my
wife got me for Father's Day last year
was a hey now shirt uh yeah it's a big
one you have three kids so that's three
what yeah yeah I know right
whoa get him this drink immediately he's
got three kids how old are they my
oldest he's a junior in high school he's
15. he's like learning to drive I had
like a whole life before comedy when I
showed up my first open mic I was 27 and
oh damn kids and a third on the way so
wow oh so when you said hey wife I'm
gonna do comedy she said great yeah
there was like it was I I think it is
why I like go ahead I just want to say
shout out to uh Patrick from Joey roses
for coming through we really appreciate
it yeah thank you Joe derosa's bar in
the lower he's one of the best uh Dives
in the city great bar 74 Remington
Street hell yeah and great hair and boy
look at that skin he's like a Kendall
from Utah uh I'm from Atlanta but yeah
Salt Lake City
if you guys remember the high West
episode I'm the guy who gave you the box
I still have it I still have like a
little bit left I have a hard time just
I usually just get a new bottle I don't
like to finish the bottle sure yeah keep
it going it's campfire so they stopped
making that wine so we've got some of
the last great whiskey you do have one
of those looks that I don't think I
could get your age within 10 years yeah
a decade if you said mid-20s okay mid
40s I also wouldn't be surprised Cooper
in the face a little bit younger you
could be a character on the boys for
sure yeah right what what are we
drinking here
oh so this is your drink good choice
dust it's my cocktail of choice yeah
really I love I'm not even a big gin guy
but I love this drink it's uh very
especially for day drinking which we're
very much
I don't even know what's in a Tom
Collins uh gin simple syrup uh lemonade
yeah uh lemon juice right
like to use Agave because simple syrup
is just sugar right yeah it's uh just
fresh bees lemon Agave uh a little bit
is closer on top of the gin and the
gender brought you is also from you hey
yeah I've had a rainy and a quick funny
story behind that the guy on this bottle
is Utah's first drag queen wow
wow really that's what uh drag queens
say now Brigham Young
from Hawaii
so we started doing drag shows wow
people thought he was a woman so ah wow
they have a big drag population in Utah
I went to a bar and I saw a few drag
queens I was like all right Utah yeah
yeah don't get too drunk
I was
hell yeah I'll be there on Sunday yeah
yeah me and Ari and the boys all go
skiing once a year we do a short Wise
Guys we sell it out we make a ton of
money and then just go skiing with it
nice fine biking made you go Sushi
that's him yeah give that guy a shot
that Sushi was amazing and uh he brings
it to the Green Room yeah yeah killers
Good Egg love Utah so we you were
talking about uh yeah sorry you had a
whole life before comedy yeah and then
we went into day drinking which fits
where are you from Seattle oh wait I
knew that the Kraken yeah sorry Seattle
but I started but I live in San Diego
yeah that's where I started commenting
good choice oh yeah it's it's uh perfect
great City yeah maybe maybe the city I
would move to if I didn't live here
that's right here a lot yeah and it's a
underrated comedy scene like six clubs
you can get as much as you want three of
them are right there downtown you go up
a lot during the week I do yeah I tried
to you know it depends how busy the
touring is but usually it at least once
or twice a week I'll do because we have
a lot of good Indie shows and then
before the pandemic I ran a show you did
it the stats right yeah and uh like it
was a cool Indie show that lasted like
15 years wow every Tuesday 9 00 p.m like
100 college kids would come in and so I
did that at minimum but you know I can
depending on what I'm doing in between
San Diego and La I usually still go up a
few times a week you know and then go
out on the weekend so uh yeah so but it
started I just like showed up at an open
mic in 27 and but I was doing that like
Meandering like what do I want to do
with my life thing and then I did stand
up and I was like oh this is it I found
I found the thing yeah sure uh but I
think because I started later there was
like an urgency to like get good yeah be
a pro and with kids you got to pay the
bills keep the lights on for a living so
I was like I was on the road within like
six months I was like wow you know just
bad terrible Casino gigs throughout the
Southwest where you're doing like 25
cold you're like to open you're lucky if
you're lucky if you get an overhead
announcement like a lot of time you just
walk to this right too and like the real
bad ones that you'd still be open to the
casino yeah even an enclosed room just
people walking by you know and so uh I
did a lot of Road pretty early on but
most of it was in in San Diego and yeah
gigs are hard when it's all your people
yeah right yeah they're hard always
there's there's something about it that
just brings out I mean of course it
brings out the worst in a person right
literally flushing your money down the
toilet I did it on Friday I was just
like take my money I was you know you
get that level of drunk where you're
just like handing them chips and you're
just I do that thing I do this one p i
this is the total comic thing I do I'm
like people aren't paying attention to
me right now hey guys look 200 on one
hand okay right you got to make a scene
yeah and then and then I just lose all
my money is worth it yeah well it is a
comic they're they're similar to like
New Year's Eve gigs where you're like
you know you're just a part of what
they're doing that night yeah that's not
their whole right they go to a comedy
show in Vegas that's usually stopwatch
it depends though yeah I mean the
tickets when you become a big tickets
are pricey so I think right I think if
they they do giveaways but those casino
games like you do a casino games you're
people right yeah sure but as he said
it's still tough there's something about
it being in that that room and it's just
it's not doesn't feel like your show you
feel like the casino's giving you a
little time yes true right then you're
back out there when you go to a comedy
club or a theater it's like this is my
show you know but at the casino it's the
casino wins because you know that they
want people back out there yeah exactly
there's a limit on how long the shows
can run totally do a club out there it's
like 80 minutes max because they're like
get them out on the floor this is great
you know that they're here but really
what we want them is out on the floor
and it's also weird to be working a
casino because I can't help but [__] on
the casino
episode where they're mad and I'm like
that's what we do but uh so the end of I
just like start [__] on AC instead
I'm like that I could do right right
right right right yeah I I only did
Atlantic City once and I was like I
called it Las Vegas I was like I don't
like this place at all that's better
than mine Vegas with AIDS yeah yours is
way better ah got a harder punch though
that's not clever only Spirit flies
there what that's all you need to know
about it no Spirit leaves
there we go no it's a it's a rough City
my brother did his bachelor party there
and I just remember a strip club with a
woman who had a star of David tattoo and
I was like this is what happens to Jews
in Atlantic City it's rough no it's a
it's a sorry I'm Gonna Keep moving
if Mark decided not to say it it was bad
you know better than a Jew with another
tattoo all right there we go oh my God
good what are you talking about oh okay
okay I'm trying to dial it back that's a
good line dial it back when have we done
that yeah good point
um no AC is this is good it's
interesting very good very good uh
There's a comic uh years ago I was doing
uh loonies in Colorado Springs
yeah and um but the host this comic Ella
Gale I think of this joke I think of
this joke once a week and certainly
anytime I have a chance she goes if you
want to know what gin tastes like just
drink the water under the Christmas tree
oh I think about it every every time I
have gin and I still like it but it's
pretty apt yeah there's always jokes
that just live in your head you know
you're in the shower like oh yeah that
Todd Berry joke like I always think of
this joke maybe once every four days
like whenever I see a guy with a neck
tattoo I always think you forgot to not
do that
it's the weirdest joke but I love it
they go deep yeah they're very like
living whatever reason that's just a
perfect line yeah Africans got a few
Seinfeld's got a few yeah they just live
there in your head it's got so many of
them oh yeah he's one of my favorite uh
joke people yeah so many yours joking
about I don't know if I've said on the
Pod maybe I have but about uh his he
talks about his divorce and he's like I
really did love my ex-wife and his
friend goes how do you know he goes what
I got to convince you to
[Laughter]
kill her that's a great joke killer your
your Cadence is easy is fun to do oh he
goes in on the subway hey comedy like my
son does it what around the house well I
was like listen you can watch us I'm not
allowed near him yeah yeah comedy we're
doing it my wife any Jews here too many
you know like
I got a garbage guy drove I was in
Queens early garbage where I went comedy
out of the truck
The Working Man yeah like around the
house of Joel my son starts it and if my
wife's there like the younger daughters
are like it's like you can do the start
but don't get to any of the actual
details
not around if you and your friends are
doing it sure that's fine but not around
the nine-year-old hopefully you don't do
it to her in bed no the Taurus
we're really doing it
all right we're doing it yeah so wait I
might have some of some Rugrats someday
what's the what's the key what's the
advice what would you say as a comedian
oh yeah it's uh you you remember
um mullaney's episode of Comedians and
Cars like he's so perfectly summarized
it when like Melanie was like being like
really like I don't know I don't know if
I can do it I can't have everything and
Seinfeld goes like they don't need all
of that they just need you
um and I think that's really out as just
having like because I work the road you
know just as much as any of us on the
weekends and you're like but as long as
you have a relationship with them you
say that like that's the easy part the
the relationship is the hard part yeah
to me being me yeah that's the stuff I
can give yeah it's easier just to set
like an old school Road dog send the
check home yeah my show the other night
and she was like that was so good I was
like well it's all downhill from here
yeah right that's the one I'm good at
yeah exactly I don't know anything I
can't compare it because I only have
done stand up as a dash sure sure you
know so like that when people are
talking about ballsy I know yeah three
yeah it was uh well like my wife's an
artist and she gets like the help for it
sure you know and and also like I said
I'm also make more money in comedy than
I did at any Meandering day oh all right
it's not like I was I was killing it in
life sure I think it was more like yeah
I was like the last job I had I was
middle managing at a Rec Center so she's
like yeah I mean I might as well try
comedy maybe this is the thing you know
okay well great job the fact that you
were uh you're a clean comic must have
helped early on because I knew Comics
early on right jealous of like we knew
those guys early on they were just
squeaky clean no and they would book
corporates and they would get gigs to
the top and that would be like oh man I
want to [__] do that but I just said
I want to [__] do that so I can't do
that yeah it definitely helped get money
gigs early
um it wasn't necessarily always like for
I always say with like clean comedy like
it's it oh it shuts you out of nowhere
but it does open certain doors for you
for sure you can still do any gig but
what's annoying is the guys who like
really Market themselves as a clean
comic and they're like I'm the Clean
Comedy you know I won this killing
comedy like if you can't be your whole
brand you the goal is to find your act
and like whatever you're writing it
still has to work in the clubs like you
have to be totally you got to kill a
comic you have to be on the front lines
of cop but when you can work clean there
you're like oh I gotta I got a thing
here you know so that helped and it did
help me around because there were a
couple big church Comics that brought me
out whoa and they brought me out because
I was clean but I had no church jokes
exactly there was no like you ever show
up late to church like I got none of
that yeah
everyone's giving you the eye Church
meet and greets yeah I got none of that
you better not go to church yeah that's
my bit Yeah but I don't swear if that's
what you want
yeah yeah which is huge yeah Wise Guys
the drive guys were coming the night
before and just wipe out the whole night
oh yeah right the guys got the pushed up
Blazers yeah that being said there are
some killers on oh sure sure
yeah oh he's so underrated I agree will
you go with the eyeballs are and and
they have a big uh subscription base
right right yeah oh yeah they're huge
there was this era in San Diego comedy
when I started where madhouse which is
we where we first met you probably don't
remember I was like hosting for you one
weekend oh yeah seven years ago tough
room yeah well it was kind of on it's
like it's not a good name for a comedy
club mad house Comedy Club well I it was
a great I'll be at the Cuckoo's Nest
yeah we it is it's a loony bit yeah it's
not a good there are a lot of them out
there
no crackers not a great name
oh gosh Bonkers with the Z
that's the infamous Joe last week
a lot of those Casino gigs that I did in
like Vegas or that that was when I
started very Vegas you're not even in
Vegas you're in Prim
and Pahrump like all the borders towns
you just yeah yeah you're just trying
it just sounds like a bummer yeah and
they just it's not a gig they just set
up some tables in a side room you're
like this is really this is really yeah
I think I did that joke yeah there's a
little drummer boy or whatever and uh
but yeah those those were brutal the
strip is sad until you're off the strip
right right good point like this is
[__] sad yeah this trip can be fun
for for like I've always I was in AC for
one night and I was like that's great
that's all you need I had a great one
night it's a hooker you don't want to
date it you know that's what's tough
about those Vegas clubs though like I do
Brad's Club a lot and it's like a week
seven it's way too you get in Monday you
leave Monday so many and that and they
put you up in a really nice room and the
show is fun but it's like goodness great
that's way too long and yeah it gets
real sad that's why I never I know a lot
of guys who have gambling problems real
addictions and I just couldn't I like to
gamble but it's so sad in a casino that
it keeps me from gambling well I do it I
don't do doing it alone is sad oh
there's a bunch of people I'm kind of
like I lost some money but it was
entered that's true yeah you're paying
for a night outfit the drinks yeah but
uh yeah there's two vodka sodas so that
was really worth the 900 I lost
but the slot lady and the respirator and
the smoking and the old lady with the
camo hat and the limp and The Rascals
yeah yeah
too much two mile walk back to your room
that can be a that can be Bleak the bad
carpet yeah yeah the ding ding ding ding
in the background brutal I'll do Vegas
once a year usually uh if I do Brad's
club and but like I'll make like a trip
out of it like my family will come or
something like we'll have because it is
it's just way way it keeps you from
gambling too it's smart yeah yeah that's
true and Vegas is like a it's an
entertainment City now so there's enough
for him to do sure sure but even then
you're like I don't know if this is
making it happier sadder being here with
my kids like oh yeah all the like all
like the characters they're like why is
Elmo got stains on it that's what they
come back here why is Pikachu crunchy
yeah don't touch him yeah what they'll
be like I'm counting out Cookie Monster
yeah I remember one time it was right
after the The Dark Knight Rises the last
one bang came out yeah and my son goes
why is Bane fat he was like a sad love
handles Bane because he didn't do his
homework
so you know I was gonna say it uh man
house had this like Arrow when I
probably like was a few years into
comedy where it was like a Headliners
Club but it became a showcase club and I
think it was in part because like the
middles there were so strong oh really
their class like they were coming up you
would catch like it was uh it was me
Taylor Tomlinson uh Brian Simpson uh
Derek Poston like there was and then we
also had guys like Zoltan right
Headliners and it was like that's the
nightmare when you're headlining like
you have some local headliner who's
middling and yeah and if you're not
selling tickets they go up for 25 and
you're in the back of the room like I
don't I don't got this right that's why
I bring garyvee around the road that's a
nice little dog
and they got like 10 minutes on the city
yeah oh no any comic in Boston yeah oh
just buries you yeah I did it I did a
week in a Tacoma comedy club with Dennis
Regan years ago oh yeah that was very
funny funny guys some of my favorite
classic yeah yeah and he goes uh I was
like I'm from there and he goes uh you
better not do any local crap up there
and I get it now as the headliner you're
like what's up with these homos in
Revere and they're like
yeah all you have to do is say the name
of a place when you go back to a city
enough times that you can do the local
route yeah there's a headline that's
true that's kind of [__] that's nice
I remember Dennis Regan I've worked with
him a few times yeah and uh man he had a
joke I loved on Letterman well he goes
uh my dad he had one of those reversible
belts going up like on one side it was
brown and the other side he would beat
me with it
that's a great mystery and then the
button is like I always preferred Brown
yeah he's got uh he's got one of my
favorite jokes too he goes he talks
about standing in a hotel and he goes uh
yeah I I could hear the couple next to
me in the room having sex and it just
went on for so long and it was so loud
that finally I called down to the front
desk and I was like Hey like it's a
problem like the couple next to me is
having sex and uh I can't hear the woman
oh that's great that's good but yeah I
think we all have I got like four
minutes on each City now just from the
road yeah but if I can't think of a bit
about the city I just I just go opioids
like ah you guys are all addicted to
opioids and it's such an epidemic that
it's it works every time to everyone
yeah because everybody knows somebody on
oxycontin Patrick
Valley it's bad forget about it in Salt
Lake downtown it's like a video game
you're literally like this doesn't feel
like real life it's meth Frogger it
really is yeah
called meth Frogger
it's about like the ridge Utah
Housewives how they all just had you
know they're all strung out on whoa
damn
ah
and and it's so textbook like you go to
Utah a lot of Mormon blah blah blah but
there's like one half of the audience is
covered in tats crazy haircut piercings
leather jacket the woman's got fake jugs
crazy blonde dyed hair and you're like
oh you guys were then you got out yeah
they all have to overcompensate oh yeah
the other half is still wearing like
their Secret underwear exactly exactly
look like Sid Vicious and then you know
the the still Mormons all look like
Kenneth the page
yeah totally sheet White
Mountain oh I want to ski there holy
hell MILF Mountain yeah you guys
watching MILF Manor what's that oh I
don't want to tell you you'll never come
back
what is it it's just a new Bravo show
that's about MILFs trying to get laid
and uh they're all old and literally
they did I think on 30 Rock about this
remember did that it was like a joke
Island yeah this is the same [__]
incredible holy [__]
say they're all divorced and
horny I was married for 14 years
[Music]
see they want the young boys uh
see they're all horned up
amazing
was that going somewhere yeah no I just
wanted to confirm that fact
someone said sounds exactly like Nikki
Glazer and the guy who does deep fake
put her face on no way
damn it's like it's just her it's crazy
wow
yeah this show is fun because I hate
these dumb reality shows my lady watches
all of them but this one I'm like put it
on that's on Disney plus you know where
it was that'd be great if they just made
a total shift it's Mom's base that's BT
oh there it is oh porno abort abort all
right I can't find him
aboard aboard
yeah cracking any peeves guys oh I had a
good one oh yeah hold on oh well do you
have a list I had one today I uh I
wanted to I I brought this up to my wife
like two days ago I was like do I have
any and she just laughed so loud she's
like you're irritated by everything it's
like a categories of them but you can go
first if you want no no you go you go
I'm noodling I want to get you guys to
take on this one because this is like uh
this is like an ongoing debate in the
Nickerson household is uh uh uh airpod
like rules when you should and shouldn't
have a men around other people because
it drives me crazy when you're like with
somebody and they have one in or like
you see right now a lot of like
employees have them in yeah and it's
like very old school like Boomer dad of
me like you give me the good customer
service that I deserve yes but you'll be
like checking into a hotel right but
really it bothers me in like
conversation where you're like am I not
good enough for you yeah that's what it
feels like to me I was like do you do
you have to have a soundtrack to me yeah
like all right I got a podcast in this
year but then if Dustin says anything
interesting exactly maybe I'll take it
out did you have that bit about if you
take one out that's like sometimes
people give you a one ear you know but
they won't give you both oh that's funny
yeah somebody has that they'll give you
a chance yeah exactly similarly people
will do the thing where they'll just be
on their phone all the time and then
they kind of chime in when they want to
oh and then they go right back it's a
similar energy of like you're not
important enough for my full attention
yeah I know two guys in my head will do
that yeah all the time yeah the seller
oh really yeah yeah every time they sit
at the table and they want to be in the
group but they'll just wait until
something pops up that they care about
or they can say something about it and
then they go back yeah it's probably an
insecurity in my need to be liked and
all but I'm like come on it also might
just be like a with that guy might be
like an add thing where they just can't
focus right
um I get it I mean I get 80 I have 80d
but my insecurity weighs it out my
people pleaser cancels that out yeah I'm
with you I need you to like me and I
want to know that you like me so uh
yeah what if you what if you go in for
like a coffee would you have one in or
no I'll take it out when I order that's
what I do yeah yeah that's that but like
you know if you're shopping or whatever
you're walking that's great that's fine
you know I walked around the city
earlier today that's fantastic but as
soon as I want to talk to somebody it
just feels feels really rude to me no
I'm with you what about a running on the
street with someone what do you what do
you give them it doesn't depend on how
close you are yeah that's a good one
yeah I think one ear is customary right
like easily you gotta give them at least
you gotta do one you know like our
relationship I'm too weird I would take
them both out for you I do one ear for
you we're closer I know you better yeah
we text about sports all right I gotta
work up to that ear
but yeah and you know what else is bad
when somebody's jogging or something
they see you but they keep jogging in
place so you're like oh this won't last
long yeah you know they're not gonna
break their stride For Me Maybe that's
maybe it's a nice thing that they stop
because they
when you work out and you see someone
you know that's true that's the worst
like the work center I used to work at
like we still have a membership there
and I'll do shifts based on when I my
friends aren't there because I'm like ah
they're just going to want to talk to me
and catch up and stuff like that and
you're like I don't no you need places
to zone out especially exactly us being
expected to be on all the time you need
places yeah right you don't want to be
irritable yeah hey funny guy like I
don't want to do this right oh yeah
brutal but we play Hoops in a Rec Center
like every day on the road that is like
and it's like how we I already bought
shoes for the guys right Incredibles be
honest and then this hat I willed this
to happen by buying the shield yeah
dream it into existence she was bummed I
wasn't by the way breaking news here I
don't know if this is gonna be it's
gonna get picked up by Bleacher Report
but he asked me Giannis asked me he goes
uh are you a bucks fan I said I'm not
I'm a Knicks fan I said but I do love
your team I really respect you guys and
uh and he goes he was he was like this
and he goes well you never know and uh
next time I'm a free agent where I might
end up whoa and I go and I go and I was
like dude don't do this to me don't [__]
don't you [__] do this you want to be
on a losing team for 25 years
yeah oof if Giannis were Nick right now
we're the best team in the NBA I mean
that applies to a lot of yeah but it's
true yeah
not the Sonics
in Seattle
that's true
damn never getting that ear is that what
he said yeah that's done we're done if
he held out he said I won't play until
Seattle has a team they'll have a
[__] team tomorrow oh yeah that's
probably what it takes right because
it's like of a lot of our old guys
they're like our old coach like George
Carl and they're like yeah nobody cares
about that you know
yeah John Giannis could do it so I gotta
peeve yeah tell me my grocery store it's
one of these like uh hippie dippy places
and every time I ring [__] up they go do
you have a bag and I go no and I go and
they like look pissed like like how dare
you so then I have to buy a bag but I'm
like I'll just buy the bag what's the
problem but they want me to bring the
canvas tote in and so they they shame me
every time for buying a bag what place
is this uh Morton Williams on Bleaker
[Laughter]
[Music]
Dustin I don't know if this makes any
sense to you but any anyone who's lived
here long enough knows the Morton
Williams the dagostinos
they're all shitty grocery stores and
they all cost more than Whole Foods
that's right they're like more expensive
yes great it's awful yeah it's a good
it's a good business strategy yeah yeah
and here they are again shout out pull
up pull up the guy who owns gristidis
look at this guy John casimatitis weird
looking fella wow you know the guy's
name that's crazy yeah he did a mayoral
one for a minute what
cast of Adidas what is it
katsumatitis wow
c-a-t okay
so you know what it is we used to have
neighborhoods where like that was your
grocery store so you kind of had to go
there but now we have options but
they're still hanging on with these uh
overpriced
whoa God looks like a melted eraser
holy hell
incredible but he's Rich so you know
that he you get some oh yeah oh yeah
holy [__]
who would you rather have go down on you
oh I'll take the fish
Jesus Christ wow
I don't like those kind of jokes
why is it called the jewfish
huh how do you spell it
fish
damn I thought that was the salmon or
the white fish
that's more Jewish right
gefilte thank you
imagine this guy's Dirty Talk check out
this fresh produce
don't forget to lick the bag there we go
I don't understand like I'll come to you
know New York been here like 15 times or
whatever but I don't know the I don't
know like I'll walk around I'm like
where are the schools like you know like
where do you go like catch they were
playing catch with your son you know you
didn't have a dad
I tucked in it is weird they'll be like
a bodega a high school and then like a
like a toilet yeah like a Home Depot or
something yeah I don't know how like
just normal Parks domestic life I mean
there's basketball there's a shitload of
basketball courses yeah I guess I mean
you can play but that always bugged me
the people who played catch on the court
because they take up the whole [__]
course right it is a selfish move
baseball's a big game so there's no way
to get some grass yeah we need this
court well you got Central Park
Washington Square Park Madison Square
Park Riverside Park uh Bryant Park uh
what What's the one in Brooklyn the big
one Prospect Park there's a lot eight
Parks so many parks
he's got to know where they are you'll
find him yeah I was playing the street I
gotta peeve all right the guy who who
tries to make you let you know that he's
happy even though you know he's
miserable that is a p for me just
[__] own it
is a longer story that I'll tell another
time but a guy met an AC was starting
[__] with us at the tables and he was
like I got a family I was like where are
they yeah right
you're at the table losing money right
next to me you ain't better than me bro
I got a family what is that people do
that I got a family okay yeah that's to
make you happy the Menendez brothers had
a family
not everyone's happy yeah that could
really go either way like um is that
saying you're happy or you're sad he was
saying is and he's fulfilled okay yeah
clearly yeah yeah he's an AC yeah good
Lord [__] loser I got it it got
heated yeah really I mean I'll tell you
what happened oh you pleased you did you
take their college money
well it was Blackjack so no but the
dealer did okay and uh no what happened
he just kind of kept starting [__] and
it was it was he was like you know he
kept saying annoying she was hammered he
was like yeah and he was a kind of a fat
annoying fake Jolly happy you know but
he was like miserable sure and he was
kind of making sarcastic comments every
time and then uh
and then at one point I get I bust on
five cards I get like I think I had like
uh it's like the fifth card and I got
like 22 or something
and he goes he's like my Grandpa Charlie
they call he talked like that he's from
Syracuse but he's southern accent was my
Grandpa Charlie he said on a five he
called him five card Charlie and they
said if you know if you get five cards
you want to win anyway you know and I
turn to the deal I go whoa if I've
called Charlie says so yeah I think we
should rewrite the casino but what do
you say and he was pasted that yeah
hammered I was in I was having the bag
yeah yeah he was but he would have been
annoying before that and then I do
declare
I do declare this man and then he starts
getting more and more annoyed and he and
he he gives him like oh I'm from
Syracuse he was dragging he keeps
bragging me some Syracuse that's worse
than the family flag yeah so I'm [__]
Hammer so I just say Syracuse is a
[__] dump and everyone at the table
laughs yeah not wrong and he goes you've
just never been there I said Diner into
a barbecue I start naming people I've
been there multiple times I was like and
to tell you how I'm not prejudiced I am
I think Bluff Buffalo and Rochester are
pretty cool yeah
over the table or sideways were there
with me but uh that's how crappy
Atlantic City is is that you can crap or
like you or how crappy Syracuse is that
you can be in Atlantic City and be like
that place is a dump I know like to be
in the trash bad mouthing a worse trash
incredible well then he goes where are
you from and I said New York City and he
goes
you [__] loser so it keeps getting
more and more heated that was I was with
a woman at the table very very pretty
woman and he goes uh he she's he tries
to like high five us after a hand
and he'd been rude so we're just like
[__] it we just like ignore him and he
goes he goes I've never had this happen
in all my Blackjack years and she and
she says and then he bumps
I'm getting the vapors
we're annoyed by him so he goes uh
she he says I've never had this happen
and she goes really a woman has never
asked you not to touch her and that gets
a huge oh good man that's a funny line
and then he goes he calls her ugly oh
and and I was like dude she's clever I
said I'm Hamish I'm mad at my wittiest I
go you have four chins you fat [__]
Syracuse uh creature is what I say oh
boy and people are like okay and then
she you know and I was like she's not
unattractive at all she's very pretty
and he goes he goes well she's ugly on
the inside I was like well that's not
important to me
that's fine with me and it keeps going
and it keeps going and it just it's like
all night and I was like this is a
[__] we're just like fighting with
this guy and this is this is the low
point I'll tell you the low point
he keeps coming at me and by the way I
didn't even notice your Dangerfield
shirt I [__] love it whoa
whoa killer but I said I love it I turn
to one point after he said the comment a
better looks I'm wasted so I turned to
my toy manager and I say Brian I say
what if I just Sucker Punch this
[__] and he goes it's a casino
it doesn't matter that you just sold a
lot of tickets here they will arrest you
and I and I turn and I apologize I go
but it'd be good press right yeah and he
goes it would be good press yeah yeah
this is who's guiding my career I might
sell tickets in other markets because of
this yes losing Atlantic City I can
hardly see the fun of the headline funny
man takes a gamble
I'm getting handcuffed I was like Bobcat
Charlie would be okay I do declare
New York thing like or hey that's
actually another peep of mine I hate
when you like you tell someone where
you're from or a city you like and then
they just tell you they don't like it oh
I did do that to him Syracuse no defense
Syracuse come on but he wasn't saying
that much he like like uh my favorite
City to go to is San Francisco I love SF
I love it anytime you go to it's exactly
people do that they go oh what a dump oh
well don't go right it's not for you
then yeah we don't we're not actively
seeking more people and yeah in our city
yeah right I understand I live in
California a bunch of people left like
everyone's leaving you're like good
that's our main problem yeah too many
people the best when it's kind of dead
right
oh yeah pandemic baby really I loved it
no traffic no loved one torrent New York
City in the pandemic yeah real the city
was ours yeah there were no tourists
less senior citizens
you heard it here Matt salacus loved
when all the family businesses were
struggling yeah
he hates nursing homes
quit bragging
a woman asked who I was from and I said
New York and she goes
whoa
sure
oh yeah
that's what's funny about living in San
Diego though is people will like hate on
California and they're like oh you know
liberal socialist Communists whatever
and then they go where and where do you
live in California San Diego they go we
love San Diego oh you do kind of get a
different reputation yes why is it
um it's a little purple there well yeah
because it's a big Navy town and so it
is a good kind of like maybe why it's
the best comedy City it's such a good
game yeah I mean SF Crowds Are Good La
crowds are good yeah as long as you're
not like if it's your people in L.A
they're great but it's you know the
random pop-ups can be right whatever
it's a good connection to people it's a
party but not there they don't get
offended no no not at all it's very laid
back you just like uh it's because it's
a it's a Beach Town that's a city yes so
it's like a city and everyone's chill
and unmotivated and but still hot
somehow yeah yeah it's a City full of
part-time lifeguards like they're all
content because they're like well what
more could I aspire to than to live here
so there's no like big companies there
there's no like world-changing
entrepreneurs right from there they're
just like now I just was longboard of
the beach baby they don't have that
pretension of La that like I'm an actor
and all that I'm a big shot what do you
drive they don't have any of that there
because they're from there everybody in
La is not from nobody's from there yeah
everybody moves there and gets a Dodgers
hat and you're like all right right
spare me you know yeah it's
unfortunately it is a cool logo it's
great yeah it is yeah
logo though the LA it looks good I mean
I it's a classic second only to the
Cleveland Indians
the classics they do like the logo but I
don't yeah I know I hate that too yeah
it's it's nobody's when when you have a
yeah that's it's a good it's a good hat
yeah well you have in L.A in the New
York one that interlocking NY for the
Yankees or the New York one's better
yeah I'd say so this is a little square
it's a little it's a non-biased person
I'll call them equals they think that
they are you know I have no skin in the
game here oh that's a beauty that's a
great logo both Yankees and Mets
fantastic that's a New York's [__]
winning that come on my favorite uh
again I have no skin in the game here I
heard Giannis might play with the Nets
don't you dare all right I like uh
there's some great hockey logos too okay
I like the San Jose Sharks that was a
classic yeah always because of the
colors Roy wood told me he used to
always wear Charlotte Hornets gear as a
kid Hornets gears it was gang neutral
colors
yeah like a shark biting a hockey stick
hey zoc Doc there's nothing worse than
going to a doctor's appointment having
your doctor seem like they have better
places to be instead of checking you out
the doctor is checking the clock not
with ZocDoc you'll find quality doctors
who focus on you listen to you and
prioritize you ZocDoc is the only free
app that lets you find and book doctors
who are patient reviewed take your
insurance and available when you need
them and treat almost every condition
Under the Sun choose from thousands of
patient reviewed doctors and Specialists
browse doctor profiles upload and verify
your insurance information and get the
care you need go to zocdoc.com drunk and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
find a book find and book top rated
doctors today many are available within
24 hours that's
z-o-c-d-o-c.com slash drunk sockdoc.com
drunk get on it when my cat's healthy
they're happy and that makes me happy I
got a big old fat Maine [__] and that
thing shits like a rhino
so you got to have your pretty litter
all right
thank God Neil's not here but I don't
always know when they're healthy pretty
litter changes colors to help detect
early signs of potential illness in my
cat including urinary tract infections
and kidney issues I really use this
stuff I swear to God I'm gonna get a
handy later when I pull up with this uh
big bag of litter because uh my lady
loved it so we tried all these different
ones this is the one your cat's annoyed
your cat's anti-semitic the colors
change it's great pretty little super
light crystals bass also minimizes mess
and dust plus the crystals last up to a
month which means less scooping and
fewer trips of the garbage can Pretty
Little Ships free to my door and a small
lightweight bag I never run out of it
and I don't have a container of litter
taking up space and stinking up the
joint
pretty litter helps keep my cat healthy
and keeps odors down you and your cat
are going to love pretty litter as much
as we do go to prettylitter.com drunk to
save 20 off your first order that's
pretty litter.com drunk to save 20
prettylitter.com
[Applause]
oh yeah that and the Mugsy teams that
was a weird era of dudes dressing like
women that no one cared wait what
grandma Yeah
wedding dress look at his grandma this
was LJ's Alter Ego yeah I forgot I've
met LJ if it was on like Sports
Illustrated for Kids
wow he did it on an episode of Family
Matters that's right wow incredible LJ
and Urkel can kind of hoop yeah oh
Jaleel White yeah you're doing that
Ellen's cut and then Penny Hardaway had
that's right oh there's them together
that's my whole childhood and then Alan
came out on ABC a couple years ago a
couple years later very uh ahead of the
curve Medea yeah
great Shane Gillis joke
well I watched hidden figures is it
hidden figures and he goes uh where's my
dad calls it Medea goes to space Oh my
God damn
his father
damn I love it yeah did did an episode
of Full House too did someone that's
right Claire Johnson there
yeah there's some Family Matter scandals
out there too like the Eddie guy the kid
who played Eddie he killed somebody what
oh yeah Eddie yeah in real life
yeah one of the dogs in porn Jaleel
White had some problems with like how
did I miss all this yeah it was the 90s
you know it wasn't the internet
what would Julia white do
uh he just you know he's like all [__]
up because Urkel like he can't get a gig
whoa all right Sally careful there
he's a good Christian comedian over here
what the hell are you doing to this guy
he's working on the gym yeah of course
was that weird getting those Christian
you could you probably got a lot of
you're doing like Arenas right
there were some ones that were like and
I was like so new into comedy and
they're like so we're doing Grand Canyon
University today it's like okay I don't
know what that is like it's 7 000 people
wow like I'm like four years in oh wow
which maybe was good to be that
blissfully naive to it you know uh you
just walk out you're like oh my gosh
this is gigantic that's insane in the
early years yeah yeah it was uh I was
very fortunate in that way and that like
I got to be a pro faster because of that
sure yeah I don't I don't love the arena
gig I'm not I don't either a little too
echoey you know the best one I did I did
fully loaded one weekend and we did the
KFC in Louisville that was great that's
a great room yeah yeah it was super fun
but all the other ones I love comedy in
Louisville though you don't love it I I
like Louisville if I'm in Lexington if
I'm in Kentucky yeah have you done the
new club nor West open a new one yeah it
was a bit of a Heckle Fest
it was
iconic figures are Muhammad Ali and the
KFC guy and George Clooney yeah there
you go and Diane Sawyer he's Lexington
yeah who again this is a weird mix
which makes sense of why the grounds
would be so I believe Johnny Depp yeah
that's the best joke about that about
being a Jew from Kentucky and people
always say well how did that happen he
goes well my well my grandparents fled
the Holocaust they uh weren't picky
that's a great job good line
uh no Lexington's great though there's
like a good energy in the air good
energy there yeah yeah Broadway and that
one great clothes
and Jessica yeah she's one of those old
school clubs I used to do a lot of
cocaine in these clubs oh yeah he's in
the woods you can feel it yeah well
that's a classic room and uh the cool
thing about Kentucky is whatever bar
you're in even comedy clubs you're like
I'll have an ocean-aged Scotch like
whatever yeah they have like amazing
whiskey not scotch bourbon whatever but
they have great whiskey menus they like
like the way it's like a diner menu but
it's right right right
that's their thing there bourbon horses
a little bit of racism at least there's
some racial tension you think yeah yeah
oh in Kentucky
Well having Louisville in the middle of
Kentucky it's kind of like Atlanta in
the middle of Georgia yeah it's like
this is like an iconic City and the rest
of the state is really upset about a
black Little Mermaid you know it's weird
to join the club
ah yeah I prefer I prefer outside of
Atlanta personally go to the Jewish
mermaid you guys can't [__] with
shellfish
that Kentucky was neutral during the
Civil War
neutral like Switzerland or Charlotte
Hornet jacket
so nobody liked them we had the Hornets
for Texas yeah so both sides just yeah
there you go yeah imagine being neutral
just imagine me it's like the Seinfeld
episode I choose not to race yeah right
it's almost more offensive to be like ah
you know I don't really care one way or
the other yeah about human Zone and
humans I'm neutral on that one hmm I
don't know I kind of like it
did they set up Kentucky as like you
know like in tag they have base
Kentucky base you're like you can't
fight here we're safe in this area we
all have coffee here right yeah yeah it
seems like good living like every time I
go to Lexington I'm like maybe I'll buy
a place here this is not Rolling Hill I
mean I won't but it just seems nice it's
quiet nobody bothers you it's unassuming
it's one of those places the plane
ticket is always way too expensive
that's true they know that you won't
need to get there that's right you have
to cheat the system maybe fly into
Cincinnati or do something right yeah
that's some weird taint dick balls
[__] stuff going on with Ohio and
Kentucky you fly in Ohio but you go to
Kentucky or you're flying I can tell you
go to Ohio it's all wacky over there
Ohio I mean it's easy for you guys but
coming from the West like anytime you do
like hilarities you're like this is this
is more challenging than it should be
but same thing no one knows you're just
like yeah I'm going to Cleveland for
vacation oh no you I will say these days
we usually if we go east to west don't
you leave a day early usually I never do
really I can't I've been doing it just
because I don't I don't wanna especially
if I have two shows that night I don't
want to travel I don't want to do a six
hour flight yeah and then do two shows I
wanna I wanna make sure I'm on my game
yeah you know so I I will try to fly in
the night before I get it but uh I'm
like I have this happy fulfilled Life as
a father so I got a family I got a
family
yeah my family back in Syracuse I got to
spend every second with him
um he did have a fat face it was a funny
face he was so outraged when I called
him fat I'm picturing the D'Agostino's
owner in my head he did kind of look
like that oh there wow
younger than he looked oh
yeah I uh that's one of my the things
that hurts the most in Internet comments
when people call you old yeah I don't
know if you guys get that but I do with
and it stings really I had one well they
probably just think you're old because
you have you're probably my age but it's
I'm 38 hello I'm putting the stash the
glasses well I did like a joke about
like being a millennial and people like
this guy's the oldest Millennial in
history this guy this guy and these are
horribly tame I get way worse it got
worse yeah yeah I'm talking about word N
word r word yeah that's just what you're
saying yeah
comments that somebody had to caption
that somebody had to create a graphic
that came up on that uh no all but but I
was I had one day where it's just like a
video went pretty big and everyone would
just tell me how ancient I look and then
uh the internet like Lord algorithm
blessed me and they put up soder's old
clip of saying he was 29 and then I
immediately went to the comments and
because soda's a good looking dude oh
yeah and they were right here they're
like
yeah yeah and the top comment was this
guy's been 29 for 10 years oh and then
one under that goes this guy's 29 the
way Brittany Greiner is a female and I
was like this made me feel so good well
she is a female yeah but that's right
that just to read them and go like all
right this is just what it's like out
here yeah people say don't read the
comments but that's easier to do when
you're like big and successful when
you're starting you're like there's two
comments
you do get uh you do sometimes get a bit
at like sometimes I laugh oh yeah when I
read it sometimes it's an insult of me
and I [__] laugh you post them
sometimes I like to post them too
he looks like George Clooney's failed
clone oh that's cool yeah pretty [__]
funny
actually the uh the opening uh the
opening bid on my special runs in the
family villain on YouTube is about cyber
bullying and it was someone called me
like this guy is an uglier less funny
Ned Flanders oh wow that's the opening
joke about cyber bullying I was like
that's pretty good that's pretty good
finders is funny Flanders the funny one
to hit yeah the reference is everything
yeah I used to get a lot of Michael
Phelps with Down Syndrome that was a big
one yeah I got
uh really sleepy Donnie Wahlberg and I
was like that's already the less
attractive Wahlberg right and then why
you gotta add sleepy yeah you know they
gotta have some Zing yeah you're a
tedious Daniel Baldwin a tedious
because otherwise he's quite Pleasant
yeah one time I got Shia ugh
yeah that's good for a comment I
wouldn't even know how to write that
yeah yeah he put a dash in there that
works so people said uh on our subreddit
that you look like Eddie Cantor I'd say
it a little bit I could definitely see
it yeah I see it
who's here oh my by the way the guy who
guy who founded Reddit hosted this
benefit last night stop it billionaire
right there right I know I I got my
first big laugh [__] on him oh
the ruins
I said uh he brought me on stage it was
he was very nice and he did a great job
hosting actually like was heartfelt but
also like self-deprecating oh you did a
good job so I go up immediately go hey
man thank you so much for finding Reddit
without you how would I know I'm an
unfunny one eyebrow dip [__] and I got a
huge pop
yeah when those weird gigs you're like
oh if I get a good one early they told
us not to curse too so it was just like
my first line is [__] and they got a
big laugh I was like I'm cursing yeah
yeah
I tested the waters yeah if you kill
they never care they never care yeah
they've told that a million times you do
that sometimes with those gigs where you
send out some feelers like you're like
when you like crap on the company or
like a city or something like that and
you're like you like that one because I
got a worse one behind me right I got
something even meaner here you could
give me this one but they always want
you to [__] on it because you go into
your um Uber's weird and they're like
yeah all right all right but then you go
hey Bob's a douche like yes Bob talk
about Bush it's so weird and foreign for
you to be talking about yourself in a
setting of course yeah so I got kids
they're like I don't who I don't even
know who you are yeah you can't you keep
it going you're like Bob's a weird
looking guy everyone's cheering you're
like and I heard he sexually assaulted
some employees they're like
three two four listen I've done some
crowd work at corporates that I'm not
proud of really yeah well you know you
just you find the thing that they like
you're trying to like get into a bit
usually uh like if you can but like you
said you're like oh yeah this guy and
what the what I found is good is if you
can uh get the lower plate employees if
you can get them and realize you're on
their side not the boss or the corporate
like I did one it was like like a winery
and it was for some tech company and
like I came in I don't even remember
exactly what the jokes were but I was
like hey one thing I got common with uh
you guys is I'm not getting paid enough
either and we all I did a Norman voice
apparently
I was like I like that they got on yeah
it was a good like way to get in and
like the the like the boss he's Rich he
laughs he doesn't care yeah I am
treating him like crap but it doesn't
matter so there are things like that
where you're just like this is just
survival I just have to hit my time ish
I had some bad news every man in line
though to give everyone on board dude I
did a I did a like uh early on I got I
had a gig where a guy's like hey you got
like a company party in my house and I
was like okay and he's like I don't have
like a sound system though could you
bring it and I was like I guess it was
like for like 400 but I was new yeah
okay go set it up there on that side of
the pool and they'll all be on the other
side oh no and he's like I do like 25 30
and I was like okay fine I I was really
new all I had was material I don't know
how to survive in a gig like that and I
bombed for a solid 30. I mean not a lot
people kind of just went back to
partying yeah yeah I just kept going on
because I was like I gotta do my time
and I was just like looking at the sound
system that I brought I was like I want
to jump into the water with these yeah
and then I ended the gig and then I had
to tear down the equipment
like take it back up to my car oh this
picture doing like the Bill Murray and
Rushmore just that's exactly what you
want to do yeah and and uh and the guy
like didn't look at me when he gave me
the money he just kind of like looked
away and gave me some cash that was a
lot of that early on a lot of that hand
you like crumpled up money yeah they'd
be like here yo real quick I'm like this
isn't illegal no yeah you don't have to
be so what I did feel illegal I felt
like it was I didn't want anyone to know
about it you get fired from a corporate
gig like halfway through the yeah
definitely do a few of them I've [__]
up every corporate gig almost I've ever
had but two of them were really like it
shook me I was like I was traumatized
for a day or two but one I've told the
story a million times I'll give you the
quick version so guys tell me the seller
he goes come to my company hedge fund we
do it Upstate I'll pay for your train
ticket it's you know a zillion dollar
hedge when I get there it's Ferrari's
Lamborghinis the whole thing in the
driveway and it's like a white
tablecloth you know all the waiters are
just serving champagne and everybody's
loaded right and the guy gave me a rap
sheet and he goes I want you to be
vicious and I go you got it so I go up
and I'm like hey uh Kenneth everybody
knows yeah you're gay and his wife's
there she's like I knew it you know so
she leaves and a half and I'm like oh
that was weird all right and then I'm
like hey Richard hey we all know you got
a Coke problem when you go in that break
room we know what's happening and he's
like shut the [__] up but you know his
nose is bleeding or whatever and I just
did that with like eight people and
eventually the guy just went boom and
that made that feedback from you just
took the mic goes all right we're good
okay uh we hit the band or whatever did
they pay you he did not want to pay me
I'm gonna read a cigar in his mouth he
was like just take it and get out of
here just get out and I was like I do
what you ask
oh yeah he was like a big fat the
problem is when they see you at your
best yes in the right environment right
where everything aligns they assume
that's just how it always goes right
that happened to me once I remember uh
at Eastville these guys were like booked
me for a gig and here's a gig in
Bridgeport where I got chased off stage
but they booked me being like well I
mean if you're this good here I'm like
what on a Saturday night in a comedy
club yeah for 12 minutes yeah you think
I'm gonna Crush in a weird [__] part
of Connecticut right it's not how it
works not how it works yeah they always
think they want comedy they don't want
comedy they don't want to sit and listen
to your kids you know like they don't
care about that they're my observations
on life around us they don't want any of
that they picture everyone laughing and
them being like wow I brought this guy
I'm the man that's what they picture but
it's not that that happened to me I got
booed off a stage at a college whoa and
it was nice book to me they're like I
love you you're a great stuff hang on
we'll see and it was this like tiny you
know a lot of these college gigs you're
like I'm not even a real place
yeah when's the last time you did at
college for me too yeah this is
yeah this was probably seven years ago
and it was like day 13 on the road for
me which is a long time like I don't
stay out that long ago yeah that's a
doozy as a dad and yeah it was and I was
like yeah tits yeah and then I was like
I had like a I had like an infection on
like a cut I was like sick too and I was
like all right but this is the last gig
I have to do and it's in like in the
middle of nowhere West Virginia I'm
driving through and there's all like I
saw multiple garages that doors that had
been painted as Confederate flags oh wow
not just the flag yeah it was like a guy
came into that town and was like this is
a service I could offer and there's six
of the homes all said yeah that's
exactly what I'm looking for is there
any party after the 14th one where
you're like I'll just say the n-word
just to get them on my side yeah
I think Abe Lincoln was a [__]
you're dropping it this is a cotton
picking good time all right so I go
one two minutes
[Laughter]
yeah that's a dome pod with just you one
too many by the way this is one of my
favorite things about this pot is when
you guys go to your sponsors my favorite
one is when you go uh uh you'll be like
hey are you guys uh you know we all need
therapy you know we all we got some
problems in our life you need to talk
someone in your life you've got problems
and then uh anyways use promo code drunk
yeah before therapy which is like that's
what's right on oh yeah there's a market
that's exactly what they want to hear
you got that right they're not going to
forget themselves it is ridiculous we've
also like Health ones like athletic
greens it's like promo oh yeah we have a
lot of ones where we're like yeah I
don't know if this is but that's like
made me it's made me more healthy yeah
we need it who needs it more than us
yeah booze bags we need the greens it's
a great promo codes an athletic green
cocktail yeah I don't know how that's
going to taste dude
that's what we got the mixologist sure
all right yeah I know you're on board
dad because you listen to the
commercials too on the Pod
yeah like one airpod
I'll take two airpods
obviously we do them but I've never I
don't think I've ever I don't know that
one just kind of I don't know full
disclosure I was fast forwarding but
that was the last one and I just heard
therapy use promo code drunk yeah
good time so wait wait so what happened
to college oh yeah yeah so uh it's like
the classic College gig where it's not
really even a show uh they're just like
hey you're gonna go up here at six and I
walk in and there's like one table and
like two kids kicking a soccer ball in
the back of this room geez and they're
like so you go on and you're like oh I
do I have to it seems like nobody wants
this and what I didn't know was class
got out at 6 15. or no his class got out
at 605 and we were in like the cafeteria
so people started coming in in about
5-10 minutes into my set and but they're
way far away from me they're like 25
yards away from me or the other side of
a campus pool yeah exactly yeah ordering
their dinner and Wow all I can hear is
like the the sandwich lady being like
Sam turkey on rye that's all that's
that's all I'm getting that is what I
order actually yeah
uh and uh there's like a table in front
of me I'm just bombing like it's not
even bombing it's almost like it's not
happening yeah you know it's a non-gig
and I looked at like I'd start talking
to the table and I was like they're
trying to do anything to survive and she
was like why are you talking to us I was
like oh well there's like a comedy show
here and then they and there's three
girls studying they go we didn't ask for
this oh and I go you're right you didn't
I'm in your study space right here and
I'm just like but but what's happening
is a lot of kids probably like 70 80
kids are all now in the back far away
from me but they kind of get wind that
there's a comedian bombing and it starts
to kind of like I start getting heckles
in the distance you suck bro this is
awful I'm just trying to survive and I
go I'm trying to do anything I got a bit
about names or something like what's
your name the guy goes D and I go what
and he goes Deez Nuts yeah classic
comedic pause
eruption yeah like ah people are started
standing on the table
oh got him got him got it it was like
insane how Ruckus it got and I'm
supposed to do 60 and I looked down on
my phone and they're all and it says 17
minutes uh they're 43 minutes left and
they're all booing me and I go I'm good
and I just walked out good for you
because I I pardon me the comedy and the
comic is like I gotta do my time I was
like there's no winning here there's no
and so I just like walk off and I go
take a red eye from Baltimore back to
stinking City and then I wake up the
next morning to like this all comments
all over my Facebook Deez Nuts got him
got him like this kid's like trolled me
the next day now here's the worst part
about those gigs is you get off stage
and the the producer or whatever lady is
like oh that was bad and you're like
your fault it was yours this is not my
fault I'm comedian I know what I'm
trying to get money I actually was a
little scared yeah like it got it gotten
so wild that I was like I I think I'm
safe right but if nothing else they're
gonna verbally abused me as I leave I
mean there are 30 kids in this city that
think I'm the worst comedian of all time
and then I got on stage the next night
just to like get rid of it you know you
do stink it is like a fish it does yeah
until you that next step's the show I
think about that set pretty regularly
yeah even though like you get off and
you're like you do a set the next night
and I had a great set and you know
you're like no I can do this and but
you're like oh you know you're better
for it you know I was like yeah I still
wish it wouldn't have happened of course
and also you're not better for it you
would have been fine without that yeah
you're right that's one of those gigs
where I I relate to that so much that
the looking down and seeing 17 minutes
I've already thrown out your like
guaranteed crowd yes yes and you're like
three of these minutes have been on TV
exactly I got none of this [__] I got
none of my weapons left right and now
it's like it's like it's like you're
just in a shootout and you're like just
throw the guns now you're like [__] hand
to hand I guess oh my God I don't know
but I got nothing left it's not your
fault it'd be like if you were really
good at basketball and they're like yeah
got you a basketball game it's in a corn
field and then you're like well where's
the ball they just give you an anvil
yeah and you're like what the hell this
isn't fair I thought you were a good
shooter yeah exactly Hicks yelling at
you you can't dribble with that Anvil
yeah yeah I had a gig this was a lot of
money for me a lot of money and it was
in Philly and I had to get a tux custom
made that's how high-end this gig was it
was a pharmaceutical event or whatever
and uh it was at this crazy Hotel
Ballroom in Philly they got me a limo
all the way from here to Philly got my
tux on had to get fitted the whole thing
I get there three hours early they give
me a stack of note cards I'm hosting an
awards show for the best this is the
best sleep aid
nominees are and then I would do the
whole thing it was like a four hour show
it was like the Oscars for pills and I
was like all right here we go a lot of
money and they're like do 15 up top then
we'll get into the award show they had
the ladies back there who would hand the
trophies and everything it was big time
yeah and I go up and I go all right this
is gonna be a cakewalk it's like 500
people in the crowd Ballroom beautiful
Chandelier and I'm bombing immediately
immediately bombing immediately bombing
and I go all right I'm just gonna go
into a little dirty I'm supposed to be
cleaning I just got a little dirty maybe
just get them and I did a joke about how
self-checkouts are kind of like a
vibrator you know you do it to yourself
it's usually it's usually and it's a
little dirty it kills so you know when
you're fingering yourself well I did it
on Conan no I know
yeah so it's like clean-ish but this
lady goes that's enough and she throws
the napkin down like a Marx Brothers
movie and she runs out and then the
husband runs out after and she's gonna
[__] throw a pie in her face yeah
yeah and I go uh some Square old bag ah
we don't need her back to the show
bombing bombing and then uh eventually
the guy comes up to the side of the
stage goes and I go excuse me everybody
hold on I walk over and uh he goes
you're done I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
take it so he just takes the mic out of
my hand and he goes you just go back sit
down I had to sit down at the front
table with like all these guys and I go
what happened I go that was the CEO's
wife and the CEO ran out and I was like
uh
and so they're like you're fired and uh
we'll send you back in the limo you just
got to get out of here and I remember I
left and I saw her crying in the lobby
oh my God like he was consoling her and
I was like Jesus your husband's like a
pharmaceutical yeah you're literally
killing people yeah you're killing
people let's go back to putting drugs on
the streets yeah if you get the phone
call he's like more opioids yeah yeah
that comedian was so offensive yes
imagine being that right at a homeless
epidemic but that dirty joke yeah it's
your fault yeah imagine being that rich
and being married to that right just
humorless just someone yeah and also
have some [__] compassion yes if I
see an artist of any kind I'm not
calling this artist but obviously a
musician a former a performer struggling
yeah I don't I don't [__] I don't
think they suck I'm just like man that's
that's tough yeah yeah maybe it's
because we've been through it and we
relate to it but like [__] man no even
even if I don't like their act I'm just
like I try not to be hard on them right
yeah of course like the girl going why
are you talking to us even that's a
little harsh like you know why I'm
talking they booked Me Maybe you think I
want to be here this sucks you're
[__] important for everybody yeah
sometimes it's just like it's like yeah
that wasn't meant to be that right your
comedy should not have been in that no
comedy no nothing should have been in
that room yeah
I got it same thing it was like they hit
the pool of people from the computer
laughing store if there's nobody in the
audience as a dry hand and I got I
pulled out a pass
hilarious incredible
that's amazing
that is the opposite of the Apollo
pull-off is it right that is funny when
you're a clean comic and like like you
I'm getting a level now where I sell
enough tickets that I can say to the
club like hey if you could book Someone
clean-ish yeah that'd be great but I'm
not selling enough that I'll demand it
so as a helium in Philly and I told the
guy I was like did he tell you and he's
like yeah I'll work clean and first
thing it goes out very first joke he
goes so I got a baby dick it's the first
thing that goes eight pounds six ounces
which is not a bad joke by the way I
laughed that was a real laugher yeah no
that's a great joke and it finishes into
a diaper I like it but it was very funny
I was like I think the definitions that
we have of clean here are different but
yeah I will say like the crowds that I
do have there they get it they're like
yeah it's funny we're all yeah my friend
open for Galloping this is 10 years ago
and in Galvin actually like a clean
comic to open and I remember being like
that's kind of weird Galifianakis he's
pretty dirty right and it's only because
that you can just come out and go so he
[__] my ass last night or whatever and
you're like Ah that's just too dirty
yeah like it's not even funny it's just
you're just saying crazy [__] I've done
that too I'm not by any means a clean
comic but I don't like when it's
excessive I agree I agree because then
it kind of just is like well now it's
just kind of like cheapened a little bit
right totally totally and I have no
problem if they do that obviously on
their own but on on the show I'm doing
yeah I don't want there's a little bit
of Aging there thing too where I have
heard enough of this you know sure
Zoltan had a nose it becomes a special
yeah I just had a little joke about when
he went and saw Wolf of Wall Street he's
like I knew I was old because I was
watching I guess it's just a bunch of
smut up here this month's a great word
that's a very very funny that's a good
one yeah this is yeah just a bunch of
smuts yeah I do like that movie it's a
great movie great movie yeah yeah [__]
uh wrestling or whatever that was fun
[__] tossing right that was in that
movie yeah I like how you thought you
corrected yourself with the wrong word
[Applause]
it's not problematic now
um should we do a Biz I have plenty of
[__] friends
what they're on a short list
It's a small world what uh yeah what uh
should we do best oh let's do a bit all
right
what do you got Justin you want to lead
us up my list here ah sure I've been
kicking around this like idea I try it
once of
um it's kind of it's a another aging
thing where like as the the health goals
that my doctor have given me like as
we're talking about what we should do
he's like well like you know like you
gotta go on a lot of walks like you got
to do so it's just just walking like not
even running just like walk and he's
like in like push-ups like body weight
stuff but you don't have to do a full
push-up just like push your top half up
which I'm like these are literally the
fitness goals of a toddler right that's
the goal where you're just trying to get
yourself this is all I need from you is
if you could stay straight up and then
you can walk and then I was thinking
about how a lot of my pain comes from
being on airplanes Ah that's where and
I'm sure you guys which is very
embarrassing that that's what hurts us
because sitting you sit and you have a
you have a thing a Trey and people give
you snacks which is the closest version
of an adult high chair that you're gonna
get something in there just like it's
gone toddler-ish of like that's the type
of bit you would think of to it I like
it very normal I love a good compartment
there it is but uh yeah that's
interesting it is funny that that
because you think about like pro
athletes they fly everywhere right true
that's not where they're getting hurt no
no no no no you got stuff like Giannis
is out two to four weeks yeah you know
it's like it just moved just like yeah
like hiking is like almost excessive
like you don't even have to do a hill
just walk just right you you get to
these you get to a point where like it's
not even technically exercise anymore if
we could just get you to walk and push
yourself up yeah that that's something
in there definitely connecting it to a
baby because they're raising kids you're
like you're so proud of your little kid
when they push themselves sure the first
time like oh they've got good head
control yeah you could do connections
too like when your baby starts walking
or like he's walking yeah when you're
trying to work out they're like Dustin's
walking he's doing it he's doing it he's
exercising yeah yeah it might actually
be funny too about like you and the baby
you celebrate it with like candy or
something yeah yeah you get ice cream
yeah they get a crustable all right yeah
you're back in there
well also when you take a breather
that's like a time out you know you're
like I need to I need a break yeah it's
time out
well that's the other thing is there
you're supposed to do yoga or whatever
when a lot of that is just laying just
like where you can just like lay flat
the the as you hit near mid-age it's
just the the expectations and the goals
for what you're doing at Fitness are
just bare minimum just yeah you don't
even they don't even we get to age where
they don't even really want you to run
anymore like that's too much it hurts
yeah I think I heard you I'm sure you're
talking to Nate you played with like at
that rec center and was in Dallas or
something and you're like you thought
you broke your back I thought I broke my
back I was playing with these young kids
and they were [__] fast yeah oh yeah
and it's like I do that thing where I'm
like I will I will play as hard as I
physically can yeah and I did yeah and I
was like I think I broke my back it was
like a cramp but I was like on the
ground for a second and I was like and
then I was like I gave it like 10
minutes I was like all right I can play
again yeah but there was a moment where
I was like wow yeah you went just as
hard after that
we switched to half court after that I
was kind of like guys I mean at Full
Court what I had to pretend it's
hilarious that's hilarious look at this
is a half court right here yeah yeah
full court is crazy yeah it's a lot
that's too much as you sneak up on 40
you become a half court game guy yeah we
don't need to run you know but when
you're younger all you want to do is run
full by the time I get a jump shot I'm
like yeah yeah yeah those first two runs
in full pickup too yeah oh my gosh I
haven't done this in a while like go but
you wanna you're you're picking roll
game has gotten a lot better oh yeah
yeah we're doing all the sneaky [__]
we're pulling on shorts no I mean it's
funny bro I think I'm a crafty veteran
Brian who's my tour manager on the road
is like it's funny we we got uh in
Portland and these dudes one of the
dudes like recognized me he's like oh
[__] I'm pumped to play against you and
I was like all right cool yeah and he
was playing like we were playing like a
friendly game but his friend was going
at my tour manager hard and he could
play this guy but Brian my tour Majors
like he's got his pride he's playing
[__] D he's in his face to the point
that I'm like there's going to be a
fight wow you ever see that happen yeah
the guy it's the dude's fault yeah it
wasn't Brian was just like he was
bumping into him and he was like well
I'm not gonna [__] back down right
yeah so it gets to that point where I
was like we're gonna fight and like
thank God the game end but it was like
we were right [__] happening on the
road a lot for you so yeah yeah I'm
worried about it you've told two
Roasters
if a game's not over you end it my
friend funny and I do a lot of the looks
like this new hour that I'm developing
is all around like that 40s thing like
kind of connected is this is this not
the one that's out right now yeah
totally yeah I'll start I'm running like
new stuff now and in town spots and then
like but when I my tour kind of kicks
back up in May and that'll that'll be a
completely different hour than the runs
in the family because you like Gotta
Give them that new stuff but yeah I am
like it's it's just kind of connected to
that of like and this is connected to
that bit of like it's because I'm near
40 and 40s is the last age where you're
anyone and no one will call you young in
your 40s the only way you're young in
your 40s is if you die oh that's good
there's no like he's so young it's uh he
was so young right right it's only in
the past tense yeah exactly so I'm
trying to find this idea but if crowds
get you know they're there to not think
about dying that's so when you're
talking about that yeah I'm trying to be
funny oh yeah there you go that's a way
to soften it a bit yeah it's like I know
you're here not to think about death but
I'm going through some stuff I gotta
talk about it you know and I can't
afford a motorcycle so this is this is
me doing the midlife crisis stuff right
so I think that it's all around kind of
one of those things reality stuff yeah
do you find yeah when you talk about
yourself dying I don't know you can see
how crowds get real tight on oh yeah
we'll drink this stuff we try not to
think about it yeah we're trying to
think about this here in this podcast
yeah but seriously what happens uh I had
a bad idea I was thinking about I saw a
guy in the street the other day crazy
guy just in the middle of the sidewalk
everyone who walked by goes he goes oh
[__] fight you next person goes by
I'll take your [__] head off he goes
[__] you I'm gonna fight you no one even
acknowledges him no one even even bats
an eye and I think the angle I'm
thinking of is like man even for crazy
people in New York it is hard to find
what you're looking for
you know I mean like you're a single
person you look if it's a guitar it's
like yeah you know this guy can't find
another crazy guy to fight he can't find
it you can't link up with he's gotta get
a he's gonna get on a dating app to find
unhinged
there we go we matched yeah well you
know when your buddy's like man I hooked
up with a girl she's [__] nuts she's
like bring her on he wants the crazies
what do you mean in the alley always the
alley yes yeah
you can also you could play it off like
a one night stand like he beats the [__]
of the guy and he's like he's like we
should do this again sometime and he's
like yeah
that's great something there don't call
me again yeah or something yeah
something there all right unhinged I
like that's funny all right
what is it
um bumble that's funny Bumble
interesting Bumble Rumble yeah
what do you got uh all right this is a
weird one but I was at a bar and this
girl comes up to me and I was like uh
might be a fan you know it goes and she
goes excuse me are you gay
true story yeah
she was a big fan yeah and I was like no
no and she's like okay okay I'm not
you know you're getting all defense I'm
like no I'm just saying I'm not and
she's like all right all right she was
pretty drunk and I'm like I'm just
saying I'm not gay you asked me if I was
gay I'm saying I'm not good she's like
there's nothing wrong with being gay
like now she's going off on a thing
right and like she keeps harping on it
she won't let it go and I was like I'm
not gay get out of here and she was like
there's nothing wrong with being gay So
eventually I snap and I go well you're
pregnant and she's like I'm not pregnant
I'm like whoa nothing wrong being
pregnant and it hit at the bar with my
friends
but I think that could be something
because it's like just because there's
nothing wrong with it which I'm not
saying there is but I'm like it still
can be weird I'm still saying I'm not
right so the pregnant thing is like no
obviously it doesn't want to be pregnant
but like you still want to be called
pregnant
yeah I like that the stigma of gay and
Pregnant are the same well I just needed
something that she could do something
that she would be repulsed by the end
yes yeah
it is the the attention that she put on
you like why is this my fault I didn't
do anything right up and asked me the
aggressive you just don't want to be you
just don't want to be not who you are
right right yeah it's funny it's like
you never hear my truth as like a
straight guy but that's yeah and I don't
you know I'd rather be gay than pregnant
you know I get rid of a pregnancy
yeah good point oh this conversion yeah
you can shock it out yeah you know
yeah I don't know I just needed
something that I could call her
part of the bit I think that's the bit
okay
I think that it was just the turn I
think the bit is uh are you pregnant you
probably no there's nothing nothing
wrong it might be a tag there's probably
a tag in there but it's like this
[Music]
yeah yeah well you look like her right
[__] you that's like that formula but uh
yeah it might need a tag at the end just
to put a button on it like yeah to tie
it up let's throw the inward in there
she was White Norman Normandy it up a
bit what about uh I've never said the N
word on stuff
I think you're gay why because you
always say I'm gay
that's what they said she was like well
you do go around saying I'm gay no
um I also like that you said I've never
said it on stage remember is that it on
stage him ah text yeah it's it's said
when I'm brought to stage on accident
sometimes with my last name oh yeah yeah
I am
and people go I always say Dustin N word
son yeah yeah yeah
but what about uh yeah so this tag maybe
like uh
yeah it sounds like you're the son of a
black guy yeah yeah right there's like
pregnant and I'm trying to think a comp
between pregnant and gay yeah is there
something other than pregnant or do you
think that that's the trading's pretty
great it's pretty good yeah all right
I'll keep it yeah
sounded pretty done crushed at the bar
what more do you need that's true but
they were my friends it's like him at
the poker table I know yeah it's like a
bringer show right exactly I called him
a fat creature from Syracuse in a kill
and I'm like that's not my best material
was good though to pull creature out
creature drunken stupor isn't it yeah
creature Lawson
[Laughter]
all right well uh watch Dustin's new
special on YouTube now thanks guys and
uh thanks for coming on man we got some
date you want some to plug some yeah go
to the website a new hour here and uh
speaking of Utah there we go 19 to 20
and we're doing Salt Lake Breya the 23rd
do I say the dates themselves the May 26
27 Des Moines Chicago in June San Diego
home gig La Tampa I'm out there I'm
doing things a lot of dates Monday it's
more to come check it out Sammy where
you at there Freddie all over man wait
when did this come out
okay so I got uh yeah Miami Orlando uh
[__] Ponte Vedra I don't know if it's
already past this but yeah Atlanta
Charleston Durham Charlottesville
Norfolk DC
yeah baby Port Chester San Diego La
Sacramento SF and there's a few more
common I mean we got all kinds of other
are you doing the Balboa in San Diego
that's great we got Columbus coming up
we haven't announced that you know
Cincinnati Indianapolis Kalamazoo
Pittsburgh maybe Baltimore my website's
way behind Philly Wilmington uh all over
Portland Maine Richmond Hampton B I mean
so much [__] just go to my website
Charlotte Knoxville Memphis website
samuel.com shows you announcing a
theater tour this summer back out on the
theaters uh uh Australia going to UK
doing the whole rigmarole want to thank
everybody for coming out to the Vic in
Chicago for the special and uh yeah
Market on my comedy.com I gotta update
this I'll be in Oxnard California and a
few other places but uh get a bottle of
Bodega get on the patreon get a glass
get a shirt get a birthday cat sweater
watch Dustin Edwardson special and uh
yeah Bodega catwhiskey.com Cliff it up
[Music]
and
I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]